here's a concept I didn't really hear
you talk I talked you talked a little
bit about in the book but this is like
kind of a key concept for me and is the
concept of pre-selection or what Dr
David Buss calls the mate copying
strategy the idea of uh so for me you
know like I said before I host a bunch
of bikini competitions and I host a
bunch of pageants here and all the
celebrity charity events in Los Angeles
and Las Vegas I'm usually the emcee for
those things and from doing that there's
nothing like particularly special about
me I mean I do kind of have my life put
together but I've just noticed there's
just this exponential attention I get
from women when I'm in when I'm around
other women and then I have a bunch of
friends who are Playmates uh and uh
whenever I'm with them and I go up and
talk to a woman like I actually the
nervousness look that you see on men's
face whenever they go talk to a
beautiful woman that's what the women
look like when I walk up with like
highly Myers and CJ Sparks and I was
just curious like can you talk about I
feel like this is one of the most
provable and one of the most
underutilized functions when it comes to
male attraction
yeah I mean I mean there's a I mean
there's a reason why women would rather
date a married guy than a guy living in
his mom's basement right you know
because the whole pre-selection part of
it
um let me sort of sum it up this way so
one of the guys that I was working with
at one point he was he was really
struggling with his self-image you know
um he didn't have a very high opinion of
himself you know when he was younger he
was kind of fat he didn't get a lot of
attention from women in his late 20s he
kind of figured out and looked good and
I was helping him out with his online
dating you know at one point he had this
Photograph
um and he was in a nice like fitted
shirt like suit everything like that
upright he was a tall guy in the group
kind of in the middle and he was at a I
don't know a crap table or something but
he was throwing Dice and he had a drink
in one hand he was throwing Dice and
there was two women to one side a woman
to this other side and another dude
just outside of that and two out of the
three women were looking at him with
admiration like
you know they had the F me look in their
face yeah sort of thing and then the
dude was looking at him like he wanted
to be him and the other girl was just
like laughing and smiling like she was
having a great time I'm like this is the
best picture ever you can't even
manufacture this in a studio with models
and actors and here you are with this
why are you using this in your dating
profile right
um and you know he used it in the up of
course got those results so that whole
pre-selection thing it's like you know
women want to be with guys that women
have already selected and you know they
also want guys that men admire
um you know you ask anybody that does
public speaking and if they bring their
wife or their girlfriend along and they
stand up on a stage and they deliver
their speech you know 45 minutes 90
minutes whatever happens to be and they
get down off the stage these wives
girlfriends whoever they happen to be
they throw themselves at their guy
because they've now just talked to a
large room of a whole bunch of people
who've now stand up given Standing
Ovation they get the big welcome the
handshake the spotlight's on them they
love that [__] right so
um I mean it's no secret for those that
see the code in The Matrix once they
understand it but being influential and
and having pre-selection is important if
you want to do well in life and that's
not just with women but if you want to
do well in life in general yeah you're
showing competency and you're showing
that you're a leader of men there's also
these really cool studies from UNLV I
wonder if you've ever seen them when
they show when women when men are
gambling that to attractive women that
they have higher testosterone levels and
they're willing to take greater risk
also when men Drive sports cars their
testosterone levels have go up have you
ever seen these yet these studies yeah
did you ever see that poor study where
they put guys in like a Porsche Turbo
and I think they put them in like a
Camry or something like that and they
tested their serum testosterone levels
after the Porsche and their levels were
much higher that's crazy man it really
is when you think about like how can you
deny evolutionary pressure when you see
things like that that is clearly not my
test stop my testicles are not a
function of culture you know what I'm
saying they're producing this because of
evolutionary pressures it's just amazing
thing so here's here's kind of the
controversy this is like the back and
forth that Rolo and I have in order for
me to host an event with 200 girls I
have to have female friends help me out
like four girls through my birthday
party and I know there's a there's this
kind of like hard and fast rule in the
manosphere this idea that you can't have
female friends and for 99 of men I agree
that you can't have female friends
because most of you guys would get
friend zoned the idea of
if you were like let's just say you
managed a strip club or you're in a
situation where you're like a male nurse
and there's 40 other female nurses on
the on the floor or something like that
if a man has that level of abundance can
he have female friends that again the
reason why I keep bringing this up is
like a lot of times for me it's my
female friends are doing the
introduction for me and whenever I talk
to girls that are fantastically
beautiful like Playmates or whatever
they're always telling me it's their
girlfriend who introduced them to the
guy that they're dating do you
understand do you understand what I'm
saying yeah
um so yeah to that point I'm of the
opinion that men and women can't be
friends uh because generally speaking
the reason why men try to become friends
with women is because they want to get
in their pants sure now in the scenario
that you're talking about you're it's a
little bit different right like you need
like there are more accessories than
what they are friends like you're not
gonna be like hey Becky let's go uh on
this rally and drive super cars you know
3000 Miles and have a blast and drink
booze and you know drive fast Becky's
not down for that but Becky is down for
being with Mike when he's at the event
and there's lots of lights and cameras
and photographers and there's other
girls there so yeah like having those
accessories there can be helpful but but
it's situational if you know what I mean
yeah for sure I think for the most part
if most guys that were in my life what
they would do is they would get friend
zoned by all of these girls and I just
don't put that out there like I have a
friend of mine chicken she's a playmate
with three million followers she's been
married for a while and whenever I go to
a bar with her back when I you know back
back in the day we'd go out somewhere
and she would introduce me to someone it
was over Rich it was [__] over there
was nothing else I had to do and because
it was just such easy brutal game on
easy mode brutal brutal pre-selection
yeah for sure I mean that that was the
case and so that I found that to be the
case but yeah you're right in a lot of
cases like they don't want to they don't
want to go play tackle football with me
they don't want to you know hey let's go
to Jujitsu class already so I I too I
totally understand what you're saying I
think we're out we agree is number one
don't get put in the friend zone and
number two uh Justin Waller talks about
your girl should not be going on trips
to Vegas by themselves let me tell you
as the guy in Vegas Justin dollar is
correct that is a true statement and I
agree with that completely because I've
said that for a while too dude you know
you don't let them go out for girls
nights you don't let them go up for you
know girls weekends there's no traveling
to Mexico Dominican Europe and it's like
look you know girlfriends with
boyfriends don't do that and the problem
is that a lot of women they don't like
that and they'll be like oh you're too
controlling it's like no I'm not
controlling I just happen to care about
you and I'm not going to put you in a
difficult situation it's like you know
I'm not going to go and park my McLaren
at a shitty neighborhood yeah I know
that I'm going to expose it to risk I'm
going to park it inside my garage and
lock it there yeah it's so funny because
it's for me it's different it's like I'm
here I dude there are there are guys
here who are monsters trust me I've been
to Vegas many many times I know what
goes on Rich no I mean there are guys
here who are so good with women bro it
is oh my God and then some of them are
like the male stripper slash VIP host
bro
and his name is Chad too bro it is crazy
and so when I see that I'm like yeah I
kind of understand it's not a function
of like you leaving me it's like why do
you need to do this without me there's a
couple that I know here she does only
fan stuff and her husband uh he does he
does some other type of like real estate
stuff and they're always together 24 7.
always always always together and they
bring women home together because she's
bisexual and their their relationship
works really really well but one of the
things that happens is she's friends
with Dan Bilzerian too and she goes uh
just to let you know I'm not coming
unless my husband can come and her frame
is so strong when she says that the debt
he's one of the only guys that Dan lets
come to the party it's really
interesting to watch but they're always
together meanwhile if I go out in front
of Dre's you know Dre's after hours and
they're like okay a couple of girls can
come in I cannot tell you how many times
I've seen couples where the girls go in
and just leave the dude outside be on
the ropes I've seen it happen hundreds
of this popularity of guys this puppy
dog look on their face and then
meanwhile like I'm going inside and like
it's like seven to one girls to guys and
I'm like oh yeah I get this you're right
this is kind of a you know this is kind
of like you know fishing with dynamite
at this point so yeah you know you got
to be territorial with your chick I mean
you know problem with that then let her
find some other guy yeah Dr bus talks a
bit about you know jealousy being an
evolutionary adaptation it's not a
function of of being immature it's just
one of these things where I'm a caveman
and the only way I know the child is
mine is if I'm the only one in the cave
with her yeah yeah that's it yeah
definitely I really hope you guys
enjoyed that clip if you want to watch
the full length podcast you can find
that over here that clips from if you're
new to the channel make sure you hit
subscribe over here and pin down below
in the top comment you'll find a bunch
of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out